dans une méthode pour aller pour aller
au bout il faut que donner l'impression
aux joueurs que c'est impossible mais
que c'est possible si tu
travailles je voulais faire une une
Académie en France aussi mais c'est en
France c'est impossible quoi c'est
impossible parce que il y a tellement de
règles et de lois que donc je me suis
dit le meilleur endroit pour faire une
académie il me semble que c'est la Côte
d'Ivoire parce que quand je suis allé
là-bas j'ai vu beaucoup de talents qui
étaient comme ça qui jouait mais qu'on
ignorait quand je suis venu la la
première
fois je me suis entouré de de de de gens
de du du pays dont Lambert à moi
malheureusement il est mort il y a pas
très longtemps on a commencé à recruter
je lui ai expliqué je lui dis on va avec
Cat plot
de ballons on va faire trèhuile on va
faire marcori on va faire Kumassi bon il
il y a des endroits où il y avait
beaucoup plus de bons joueurs que
d'autres on a recruté comme ça 7 ou h
joueurs d'emblé quoi on est arrivé à 15
16 joueurs
quoi et donc là après on a commencé le
travail j'ai fait une base de données et
j'ai tout noté j'ai tout noté ce qui me
permettait de de voir les progrès de de
de chacun des des joueurs ou les arrêts
maladie ou tout é tout é noté tout était
noté et ça après on en fait une une
méthode on avait 3 degrés il y a
toujours 3 degr et toujours tout ça est
rester dans la méthodologie pourquoi
parce que c'est c'est la base par
exemple quand on commençait avec les
plus jeunes ou avec une autre promotion
bien il commençait par les jongles il
devez jongler avec avec le pied avec
pied gauche avec le pied droit avec
l'épaul les deux épaules avec la tête
avec les genoux et après on associait
par exemple genoux
pied tête ou pied tête genou on associe
à des trucs de manière
à ce qu'il fasse un certain nombre et
s'il ne faisait pas le nombre il devait
retravailler dans la semaine et
présenter ça à la fin de la semaine
après j'ai fait ces exercices mais d'une
manière dynamique c'està-dire en courant
le principe de de de faire des jongles
c'est que on doit contrôler le ballon on
doit être maître du ballon et ça c'est
vachement important dans le
jeu
déjà il y a jamais de blessure tous les
gestes que on fait pied nuus on n'est
pas gêné par le poids d'une chaussure ou
par le poids d'un prottimia ou qui qui
sont des poids pas pas très pas très
gros mais qui quand même gêne fait que
la vitesse de de
d'exécution dans un geste de contrôle
par exemple est bien est bien faite
beaucoup mieux faite pied nu que que que
avec des chaussures ne pas jouer pied
nus pour un gamin c'est perdre beaucoup
de temps pour le la sa
progression on garde un lien oui oui eux
c'est eux qui gardent le lien souvent
parce que ils voyagent alors que nous on
bouge pas quasiment quelque part ouais
j'ai été leur père quoi pendant pas mal
de temps
euh donc euh oui
parce que j'ai fait avec eux comme
jeaurais fait avec mes enfants on garde
des liens et la meilleure preuve c'est
que l'Académie du
Mali moi j'ai dû la financer je revenais
de de de Belgique à l'époque j'ai
j'avais un peu d'argent et donc j'ai
financé au départ mais après je devais
avoir j'ai cherché des actionnaires pour
pour pour pour nous aider et o où j'ai
cherché des actionnaires bah j'ai
cherché les actionnaires dans les chez
les académiciens et donc trois d'entre
eux plusieurs ont dit oui et puis mais
n'ont pas suivi et trois d'entre eux ont
suivi il a marqué le foot ça a été un
joueur qui a fait une grande carrière ça
on peut pas on peut pas le N j'aurais
bien aimé qu'il soit le le président de
de la Fédération j'aurais bien aimé
qu'il le soit parce que c'est c'est
l'avenir de du du
foot l'avenir du foot c'est des gens qu'
comprennent mais c'est pas des des des
présidents qui qui arrivent on des
d'autres sociétés dont il faut qu'ils
s'occupent vous voyez non l'avenir du
foot c'est c'est de mettre à à la tête
des fédérations des gens qui qui soient
des anciens joueurs de qualité qui qui
ont un petit peu un cerveau qui marche
pas trop mal euh et puis qui qui
choisissent des des des entraîneurs ou
des ou des des gens
compétents c'est ça l'avenir du foot en
Afrique sinon vous ne gagnerz l'Afrique
ne gagnera
jamais ne gagnera jamais une coupe du
monde